yo Anacapa two is in her first year of
culinary college in Athens she's
starting with the basics peeling and
chopping it's a big change before the
recession her family was wealthy and she
attended an elite American School in
Athens but her parents were hit hard by
the financial crisis and you Anna had to
bury her hopes of a high-flying
international career for now at least
learning culinary skills has given the
20 year old a new inspiration our food
is a great asset for marketing our
country I mean we have such great food
that it's definitely a huge resource
when it comes to dealing with tourists
when it comes to boosting our economy
it's something that Greece should
promote because we have food I mean it's
just up to us to promote it in the right
way joanna is part of a new generation
of young people who've grown up in a
poor Greece one that bears little
relation to the more successful country
their parents once knew you Anna lives
at home with her mother who is now
divorced Senia cava to also works as a
chef at a local embassy it's a tough job
she says not one she would have chosen
for her daughter yet she has nothing but
respect for the choices you anna has
made active what has children of the
crisis this generation is being forced
to have a more realistic view of the
world maybe that's also why they're
prepared to take steps that my
generation isn't courageous enough to
take a keep women can improve you anna
is keen for Greece to find new ways out
of the crisis that's why she'll be
voting for Alexis see pass and the
opposition syriza party she's confident
they'll do the best job
I don't think it's deep rest just
because it's c plus I think it's because
it's anyone new you know we want new
people younger people on the political
scene we want to see something different
it doesn't matter nowadays if it's left
or if it's right you know ideologically
it's just different we want something
different Greece's future is also a
topic of conversation at her college
it's a private school the course costs
money and you Anna wants to be sure
she's investing properly p SI mas para
la Vega it could be 10 more years before
our labor market is back on track but
young people don't have that kind of
patience for their lives are starting
now and I can't really blame them
because they want got the audition maybe
after all yoanna certainly doesn't want
to wait ten years she signed up for
online correspondence courses in
statistics to improve her career
prospects she works as a waitress to
finance her studies you anna has learned
to be disciplined and ambitious she's
hoping for a change of government after
Sunday's election and a brighter future
for Greece